in the next 35 years we'll have to
produce more food than all of the
world's production combined over the
last 2,000 so what will the Farms of the
future look like well they're unlikely
to look like this just yet but many of
the Sci-Fi looking elements are already
on the way take automation these concept
robots are being designed to
autonomously scout sense and treat
invasive Pest and pathogens with micro
amounts of herbicide or pesticide vastly
reducing the cost and environmental
impacts associated with these chemicals
this is known as Precision farming and
see here how the lasers on this tractor
can detect the presence of weed to only
treat affected
areas and this is the ladybird Rover a
working solar powered prototype that
conducts autonomous Farm surveillance
mapping and weed
detection drones are also tipped to play
a big role in The Farms of the future
like this octop at rothamstead research
this bbsrc funded demonstrator
technology could help the farmers of the
future measure growth and biomass and
detect stresses to crops from pathogens
or lacks of nutrients or water other
researchers are already using them for
surveillance sewing seeds and even to
find or her farm animals as you can see
here vehicles like these utilize the
latest Advanced sensors and the Farms of
the future will be packed with them
multi and hyperspectral cameras for
example Le can see problems that the
human ey just can't and want 24 hours a
day feeding data back to Shared cloud
services for analysis and action and it
doesn't have to cost a fortune even now
a lot of this data can be gathered
calculated or uploaded by smartphone
upgrades and apps meaning the benefits
can be cost effective and realized
quickly in developing countries too
tomorrow's Global Farms will therefore
be key users of The Internet of Things
whereby vehicles and Equipment can use
GPS and Wi-Fi to talk to each other
connect with weather and pest forecasts
as for the Farms themselves the future
Farms might not all be on the ground but
under it instead or integrated with
factories businesses and harnessing
local energies and
opportunities the Farms of the future
will also make use of data from large
scale experiments such as the bbsrc
funded Northwick Farm platform and the
scanalyzer then there is the national
plant fomic Center also funded by
bbsrc to feed the planet in an
increasingly globalized food system and
in the face of climate change and
extreme weather we'll need elements of
all this amazing technology and more
bbsrc funded researchers are working
with partners and collaborators across
the world to realize this
vision